Sao nay ngày 22 tháng 30 năm, chúng tướng với thành tùng, giảm đốc công an thành phố hành đổi cùng đại táng nguyễn thình lòng.
Đại tài lên và nguồn, phó giảm đốc công an thành phố và chỉ vi một số phòng trước năng đã đến bệnh viện Trung Quốc
cơn đổi một chăm mình tảm tham họ. Đông viên đã ưới lên điên công, cãi bộ phòng cạnh sách cơ đổ công an thành phố và gia đình.
Đồng chiến lên điên công bị thương cho khi làm những vụ bảo vệ buổi hợp lựa lễ kiện nghiệp tảm nhanh ngày các bạn tháng
và có kháng ngày 12 tháng chiến và tựa qua.
Tại bệnh viện Trung tương viến thành tùng cùng đoàn đại anh cần tham họ ở tình yểm xu khỏe, đông viên tình thành đại ý công và gia đình.
Đồng chiến rằng đốc công an thành phố viện bử dân tình thình chắc nhận, giống cảm biến nước quên thân.
Bây giờ phục vụ của đại ý công cho quá trình thực hiện những vụ bảo đảm anh, chất tự, có phần giữ gì cuộc sống mình ý cho nhân dân.
Trung tương viện thành tùng đã chức tiếp trở tạm măng khai của chủ tịch i bán nhân dân thành phố hạn nội cho đại ý lên điên công vì thành tiếp xuất sách trong công tác bảo đảm anh.
Chất tự vụ vụ các hạn động trong mừng kinh nghiệp tảm viên năm các mạng tham thành công và khó khánh ngày 1 2 thử chiến.
Chất đổi với lãnh đạo bệnh viện đồng chi giám đốc công an thành phố hợi lời cảm ơn trên thành đến đựa của ý,
bác sĩ bệnh viện Trung quyền của đổi một chăm niên tám đã hết làm, tất tâm khu trở đồng chiến lên điên công qua cơn vì kịch.
Đông thời, đế nghĩ bệnh viện tiếp tục quan tâm, chăm sóc, đều chỉ cho đồng chi công nhân trong bình phục, ông định xu khỏe giống trở về vời ra điện đồng lượng.
Đồng chi Trung tự vấn tháng tùng cũng chỉ đạo phòng cạnh giác các đồng phối hợp các đồng viện tiếp nha cần chương tức hiện đề đủ chiến độ.
Chỉ sẽ theo quy định tạo đều kiện đề đồng chi công ít tâm đều chỉ cũng như hỗ trợ, đồng viên gia đình trong sóc tốt nhất cho đồng chi công.
Thái mặt gia đình chỉ chính thị lan, bởi đại yên lên điên công, suốt động mẹ tỏ lời cảm ơn xấu sắp trước sự quan tâm.
Đồng viên ký thời của các nhân đồng chi giám đốc công an thành phố các đồng chi trong đảng yì, bác giám đốc công an thành phố, chỉ vì các phòng trước năng cùng đồng chi, đồng lượng.
Đồng viên giữ đỏ, khoảng 20% của khoảng 20% xin năm 2020, chú xá phút thị, hà nội, điều khiến sẽ máy trở thả nguyễn văn quan,
xin năm 2020, chú xá tiến thắng, hà nội, lưu thông với tốt bộ cao trên đường viét tạm vẻ ô cơ.
Thật đến nay, các lực lượng công an thành phố hà nội đang làm những vụ bảo đảng Anh Ninh, an toàn tuyến đường vụ cụu mội hợp lựa lĩnh kiểm tảm với năm 2020 và có khánh ngày 12 thả chính.
Phát hiện hai đối tượng của hành viên nghiệm, người anh hưởng đến đoing giữ miên giữ hành và anh tọn của con chú nhân dân.
Đại ui lấy đình công và tổ công tác làm những vụ tại chốt bảo vệ trước xô ba ba sau ân nghe tạm.
Phương không hà đã ra hiệu lệnh dừng xe.
Tuy nhiên, các đối tượng không trước thành mà lao thằng xe và đồng chi công làm đồng chi công và cả hai đối tượng á xuống đường.
Lược lượng làm những vụ đã nhìn trong không xe, bác giữ các đối tượng và đối tượng chi công và bình viét cấp cứu.
Hình ra đối công không ăn thành phố đã chỉ đạo các đường biện nghiệp vụ khẩn chương đều tra cũng có hồ xe,
sống đưa các đối tượng ra xử lĩnh nghiệm mình theo quy định của Phát Lật.